翻訳: Toshiro Suzuki
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん
テレパシーって 分かりますよね？
私が考えていることが
自動的に皆さんにも伝わるという
あれです あれ
じゃあ いいですか？
皆さん 準備いいですかね
いきますよ
ハァーーーーーーーーー!!
どうでしょうか？
私の素晴らしいアイデアが
もう既に皆さんのところに届いたかと思います
あれ？ おかしいな…届いてない？
届いてない
まあ 今日はちょっと
何か調子悪いみたいなんで
まあ しょうがないので ですね
順を追ってお話をしていきたいと
そういう風に思います
私は 子どもの頃から
妄想することが大好きな人間です
私のこの妄想の 考えていることをそのまま
誰かに伝えることができないか？
このことも考えてきました
そして 色んなこともやってきました
小学生の時には 漫画家になることを決めて
壮大な冒険の物語も描きました
でも あまりにも絵が下手過ぎた
高校生の時には
ミュージシャンになると心に決めて
ギターの練習をして
大きな大会の予選にも参加しました
でも 才能の差が激しすぎる
ミュージシャンはすぐに
引退することになりました
小説を書いてみたこともあります
３時間で筆を折りました
この頭の中にあることを
何とかして他の人に伝えたい
そして 他の人の頭の中にあることも
見てみたい
この興味はだんだんと —
人と人とが普段している
コミュニケーションとは何なのか？
私たちが持っているコミュニケーションを
超えていくためには
どうしたらいいんだろうか？
そのことに興味を持ち
考え続けてきました
どうでしょうか 皆さんも興味がある分野の
ひとつではないでしょうか？
私は この問いに対する鍵のひとつが
今日私も こうしてしていますけども —
ウェアラブルコンピューティングといわれる
人が身につけるコンピュータだと
信じています
ウェアラブルコンピューティング
「着る」という意味の「wear」に
「able」で 着ることができる
「computing」は
コンピューターを使うという意味で
「着ることができるコンピュータ」
という風にもいわれています
それではコンピュータをどんどんどんどん
小さくして このメガネや腕時計に入れれば
それはウェアラブルコンピュータと
いえるでしょうか？
今日現在 多くの場合 専門家の間でも
そうやって大きいコンピュータを
こう小さくして ここに入れれば
それはウェアラブルコンピュータ
だということになっています
でもしかし 私は
これは違うという風に思っています
多くの方々が
これは私たちが普段使っている
スマホやパソコンの延長線上に
あるものだという風にも思っています
私が言っているウェアラブルコンピュータは
常に人と一緒に行動をし
人の機能を拡張するというものです
人の機能を拡張するって
どういうことでしょうか？
これは ちょっと分かりやすいために
ひとつの例をお話をしたいんですけれども
ウェアラブルとはちょっと違いますが
皆さん電動アシスト自転車は
乗られたことがありますか？
電動アシスト自転車っていうのは
ペダルにかかる 漕ぐ力を自動的に読み取って
坂道とか力が必要なときに 自動的に
モータが漕ぐのを補助してくれています
もう自分の力でどこまで漕いでいるのか
どこからがモータの力で漕がれているのか
それが解らなくなるぐらいに
自然に自分の体と一体になっている
ような形で機能しますよね？
ウェアラブルコンピュータも
同じように機能します
私たちが今までやっていたような
キーボードやマウスや
タッチパネルを押したりする必要もありません
こうやって装着しているだけで
私たちの行動や 日々の生活を読み取って
自動的に 適切に機能してくれるものです
例えば 私が羽田空港のほうに
向かっていくと
ウェアラブルは「あれ？飛行機に乗って
どこかに行くんだな」ということを察知します
そして到着した先で
私が一日中重い荷物を持っていて
疲れているというところから
それを自動的に判断して
「タクシー乗り場はこっちですよ」
という風にアシストしてくれます
そんな風にコンピュータがどんどんどんどん
人の機能を補助サポートしていくようになると
どこまでが人間の機能で
どこまでがコンピュータの機能なのか
それすら解らなくなるぐらい
電動アシスト自転車と
同じようですよね —
そのぐらい自然なものになると
いう風に考えています
そんなウェアラブルとの出会いが 今 今日
私たち そこの入口のところまで来ています
今日現在 ウェアラブルが人間の機能を
拡張していることのひとつに
「視点交換」というものがあります
視点交換
ちょっと聞き慣れない言葉かもしれませんが
決して難しいことを
言っている訳ではありません
ここにちょうど
カメラが付いているんですけれども
こうしていると 私が見ているもの
この風景が
このカメラで捉えることができますよね
そしてこのカメラで捉えた映像を
もうひとりの人のウェアラブルの
目の前に付いているディスプレイに表示します
そしてその人のカメラの映像を
私のこの目の前に付いているディスプレイに
表示することによって
ふたりの視点を交換している
これを 「視点交換」という風に言っています
それでは視点交換について説明をした
簡単なビデオがありますので
ちょっと一緒に見てください
（音楽始まり）
[レッスン：有名シェフを自宅に招く
リモート料理教室]
シェフ：厚すぎですね
5mm幅ぐらいで切ってください
生徒：はい 解りました
生徒：こんな感じでいいですか？
シェフ：はい いいですよ
（着火する音）
（肉が焼ける音）
シェフ：「ジュー」っと音がするくらいです
「ジュッ」 だと熱すぎます
生徒：これぐらいですか？
シェフ：はい 適温ですね
生徒：はい
シェフ：表面が半熟状になったら
卵を巻いてください
生徒：半熟状ってどれくらいですか？
シェフ：表面に卵液が無くて
四隅が剥がれるくらいです
シェフ：右手で菜箸を使って
左手で反動をつけながら巻いてください
いいですね お上手です
（音楽終わり）
ビデオの中で フライパンが
「ジュー」っという感じ
解りましたでしょうか？
映像の中のふたりの人が「こんな感じで」
という風に 会話をしていました
それぞれふたりの人の目の前の空間を
それぞれ交換しているからこそ
私たちが普段使っているような
「あれ」「それ」「こんな感じ」
といった言葉で やり取りを
することができています
つまり これは視点交換をすることによって
文章とか説明といったものでは
伝えることが難しいノウハウとか
ものごとのニュアンスみたいなものまで
交換することができているという風な事例です
つまり 私たちはこのような
視点交換をすることによって
少しだけ 自分の機能が
ふたりの人が一緒に居るということによって
拡張されているということが
ビデオからも見ていただけたと思います
そして他にふたつ
視点交換から新しい可能性を感じています
ひとつめは 人のクリエイティビティ
創造力ということに対する分野です
ちょっと想像してほしいんですけども
人が何かを じぃっと見ている時に
私たちはそれについて
何か意見とか興味とかを持っています
そして同時に 複数で
それぞれの人がものを見ていると
それぞれ違うポイントを見ているので
それぞれの人たちが違う考えを —
同じものを見ていても違う考えを
持っているんだなと感じる瞬間もあります
例えば 間違い探しとか
パズルみたいなもの —
ピースをずっと探しているんだけども
見つからないんだけど
隣からだれかが来て
ピュッと入れる みたいな形ですね
そんな風にして
自分が見ているものが
自分の考えを
投影しているという瞬間があります
例えば このパズル 解りますでしょうか？
知ってる方はちょっと黙っていてくださいね
じゃあこれ こういう風に解きます
見えなかった丸が出てきて
1 2 3 4
という風です
実際にですから 4本でつなぐことができる
というクイズですね
そしてこれでも解るとおり
私たちが普段
自分がちょっと想像していなかったことを
他の人が気がついたり
ということを体験することができます
視点交換をしているからこそ
この体験ができたり
また 他の人が気がついたっていうことを
また自分でもう一回
追体験をするということも可能です
もうひとつが
人の共感という分野についてです
例えば同じものを見ていて
それについてお互いが理解をしているときに
私たちは共感ということを持ちます
例えば よく目につく
ショーウィンドウの中の好きな服の色とか
よく見かける花とかっていう風ですね
視点交換をしているときにお互いの人が
そんな風にして
共感を持つということが可能になります
そしてそういうことが続いていくと
私たちは共感のその一歩先
その人と一緒に居るなあ とか
例えばその人と精神的につながってるなあと
いう気分にもなります
この視点交換によって 今お話したように
人と共感を持つだとか
人のクリエイティビティが拡張されていると
[感じる]機会があります
これはつまり このウェアラブルによって
私たちの機能が少しだけ拡張されていると
いう風に言ってもいいのではないでしょうか
これは私の友人の話ですが
彼が大学時代にアフリカに行って
ボランティアをしていたことがあります
そのとき 彼は道路や井戸を作る
ボランティアをしていたんですが
現地で友達になったのが ジャコブという
同じ年の青年でした
ジャコブは村一番の勇者で
なんとライオンを４頭半も倒したことが
あるという すごい奴です
その土地では
ライオンを１頭倒したことがあるだけでも
お嫁さんと数十頭のヤギを手に入れることが
できるという土地柄だそうですので
さぞかしと思いましたけれども
実は彼は
逆に４頭半も倒したことがあるとなると
村同士で どこの村からお嫁さんを出そうか
ということが会議になってしまうぐらい
そのぐらい 勇者だということだそうです
そしてボランティアが終わって
帰国の途に就くときに
友人ジャコブに約束してきたことがあります
日本に帰ったら 一生懸命働いて
村に道路を寄付するという約束でした
残念ながらまだ
道路を寄付することはできていませんが
その地に道路があるということは
人が往来し 物資が運ばれ
医療がもたらされ 教育が充実する
ということを意味しています
今日私たちは彼に
ウェアラブルがもたらされた未来の世界に
心を馳せています
彼が日々 体験する
草原でのパトロールやライオン狩りは
動物学者にとっても新しい
新鮮な体験となるでしょう
雄大な自然や草原をわたる風を
彼と一緒に感じることもできるかもしれません
そんな風に文化が違っても
日々を想う気持ち 家族のこと
多くの共感から
まるで彼が隣に住む友人のような
そんな人間関係を作ることも
可能かもしれません
彼自身も伝統文化の中に暮らしていても
世界の人たちと
深いつながりを作ることも可能になります
もう一度申し上げますが
ウェアラブルは
人の新たな能力を拡大するのです
ウェアラブルとそのテクノロジーは
人と人とをより深く結びつけ
人のクリエイティビティや
共感を高めることの
役に立つというところにいます
私たちは既に
そんな未来の入り口に立っています
ちょっと想像してみてください
皆さんが
共感し合い 想像力を働かせ合いたい相手は
誰ですか？
ありがとうございました
（拍手）